Rusia acaba de confirmar hoy que el
acuerdo por las exportaciones de cereal
y grano ucraniano que fue negociado en
Turquía en este mismo mes de julio de
este mismo año a través de la mediación
de Turquía y de Naciones Unidas y que
fue roto por Rusia este pasado sábado
continuará
en los próximos días A partir de hoy
mismo fue roto este acuerdo por Moscú
este sábado después de un ataque en
contra de la flota naval rusa en el mar
Negro se acusa a Ucrania de estar detrás
de este ataque naval con drones
acuáticos Rusia lo rompió ese sábado
pero el acuerdo siguió funcionando
durante todos estos días a pesar de La
retirada rusa a Turquía Naciones Unidas
y Ucrania siguieron con las
exportaciones de cargueros y buques
ucranianos después de salir de Ucrania
para llegar a Estambul donde las
inspecciones de dichos cargueros
continuaban sin inspectores rusos nos
contaban ayer de hecho miembros del
centro de coordinación conjunto Donde
había extintores rusos que las
inspecciones continuaban y que después
se informaba al lado ruso he retirado de
la mesa de que estas inspecciones y
estaban siendo llevadas a cabo de una
manera satisfactoria a partir de hoy los
rusos volverán a la mesa para continuar
con las exportaciones que según ha
explicado Moscú
representarán nuevas garantías para para
Rusia Rusia ha querido asegurarse y
cerciorarse no atacará más a la flota
rusa en el mar Negro parece según ha
dicho este mismo Miércoles por la mañana
el Ministerio ruso de defensa en un
comunicado que así será y que Ucrania se
ha comprometido por escrito a garantizar
la seguridad de Los buques rusos en el
mar Negro